This is the new Hero4 Session, and it's tiny.
And it's completely waterproof without any special cases.
This $400 camera measures only 1.5 inch cube.
It's so small and so light that it can fit in places like under my penny board.
Other GoPros cannot.
To make it the easiest GoPro to use, there's only one main button on the camera.
Press it once to start recording,...
...and hold it down for three seconds to start a time lapse.
Audio is also supposed to be clearer when the camera resurfaces from underwater.
If there's one downside to the Session, it's the sealed battery.
You can't swap it out if it dies.
That said, the battery is good for two hours of video recording on a single charge.